governor sisolak announcing thursday
that he plans on easing the state's
restrictions also on large gatherings
starting in march which means we could
see fans in some limited capacity
back in sports venues here in las vegas
very soon going to be good to see brian
so many of us
cannot wait eight sports now kevin
martin spoke to several local sports
fans today
kevin joins us live outside one of those
venues the las vegas ballpark with more
on those fans reactions kevin
well good evening brian this is music to
sports fans ears as more people are
vaccinated and
covid figures continue to decline here
in the state of nevada
governor siselek announced on thursday
that he will be loosening up
some restrictions for for the first time
since november and that means
that for the first time we will see fans
in a limited capacity
very soon including t-mobile arena here
at the las vegas ballpark
as well as thomas and mack and
allegiance stadium to name a few and
sports fans across the valley
can't wait to safely cheer on their
local teams in person for the first time
since march
as long as the safety's there they have
everything mapped out and they feel
comfortable as well as the government
feeling comfortable putting us out there
yeah i can't wait to build
our community again get the buyers going
because when the knights did come out
here they brought us all together
that you know fell a little short but
that was a great season at least the
community coming together and even the
traffic coming in and out
as far as the lower league teams i'm
still excited because the dollar beer
nights were awesome
and for a majority of the sports
organizations that we did reach out to
they're still working on a proposal to
submit but
las vegas motor speedway president chris
powell said that they are
submitting a proposal seeking 20 percent
capacity which is about 25 thousand fans
for race weekend march 5th through the
7th reporting live outside las vegas
ballpark kenny martin 8 sports now